i guess hosted for a week and i'm so
glad i don't do it every day
joy did tell me that i was talking too
much
yeah so lisa ling recently made her
return to the view as a guest co-host
but don't expect her to make it a
permanent thing this is why the view is
popular for this exact reason the 48
year old journalist who co-hosted the
daytime talk show from 1999 to 2002 was
a guest on jimmy kimmel live on monday
and recalled what it was like to return
to the panel all these years later you
know you really have to express your
opinion so vociferously on that show and
in the age of social media you're just
scrutinized so severely lisa told jimmy
she got into a heated argument with the
ladies on her first day back after she
said president joe biden should
apologize to the american people for
calling fox news's peter ducey a not so
nice name on a hot mic
what a stupid sound
i just think he should acknowledge that
he was a poor example for well but no
i'm sorry you should acknowledge he's
human
because that happens sometimes when
people ask you endless stupid questions
from one particular place uh and
sometimes you just lose it for a second
they were saying well he apologized it's
okay and i said no
that like that is not behavior becoming
a of a president right and
it was a little bit of a debate as a
result lisa says she got some negative
press
people like a train wreck and that's
when she made this claim during a
commercial break joy did tell me that i
was talking too much allegedly a rough
review from joy behar we don't like to
have fights with each other and when
jimmy suggests that there might just be
too many people on the panel lisa agrees
it is really difficult to get a word in
edgewise i i did a little bit better
this time i mean i was 20 i was 26 when
i did the show the first time around
it's actually something lisa and joy see
eye to eye on
it's much more fun to have
fewer people i think because you can
talk more we can say more to each other
even it became like i gotta get a word
in here now you know but lisa isn't the
only former co-host returning to the
panel this season e.t confirmed that
meredith vieira elizabeth hasselbeck and
star jones will be back to guest co-host
the show this month the ladies will make
their appearances on separate dates to
celebrate season 25 of the view well i
think we're going to look for people
that can bring an opposing view i mean
we're not looking for fights we never
are but we just want people to have a
lively spirited debate of course this
all comes after whoopi goldberg was
suspended from the show for two weeks
following this controversial comment she
made on monday let's be truthful about
it because the holocaust isn't about
race
it's about man's inhumanity to man
whoopi issued an apology on monday night
and on tuesday kim godwin president of
abc news released a statement reading in
part quote while whoopi has apologized
i've asked her to take time to reflect
and learn about the impact of her
comments she also sent a note to abc
staffers regarding whoopi's comments the
culture at abc news is one that is
driven kind inclusive respectful and
transparent whoopi's comments do not
align with those values
[Music]
you